[موسيقى]
من طبيب الى لاعب شطرنج محترف تعادل مع
الاول عالميا وفاز على الثاني باسم امين
اسطوره الشطرنج في مصر وافريقيا
[موسيقى]
رياضه زي اي رياضه ثانيه زي الكوره زي
السكوات زي اي لعبه ثانيه موجوده وليها
لان حد يمارس اللعبه او يتعلمها او ان هو
كمان يبقى لاعب محترف فيها مش شرط ان هو
يكون عبقري يعني لا طبعا الشطرنج فيه
دلوقتي هو زي ما بقول لك هو علم واي علم
بتقدر ان انت تدرسه وتبذل في المجهود
الوقت الكافي في دراسته اكيد هتبتدي ان
انت مستواك يطور فيه واحده واحده تتميز
فيها فاكر وانا صغير
سنه كنت بحضر في همم
المباراه يعني كنت في بطوله مفتوحه في
اسبانيا
فحضرت افتتاح وكنت نحلله مع الكمبيوتر قبل
ما اخشه ودخلت لعيبته فعلا وبعد ما لعبت
يعني موقف اللي هو لغايه ما انا محضر اللي
قدامي لعب نقله اكتشفت ان الدور خلاص بخسر
يعني لكن دي طبعا من الحاجات اللي الواحد
بيتعلمها ان هو ما ياخدش التقويم
الكمبيوتر كده عميان يعني
[موسيقى]
طبعا بالنسبه للطب والشطرنج يعني في حاجات
كثيره جدا ما بينهم مشتركه لكن هم الاثنين
من اصعب المجالات من احد يدرسها يمكن
بالنسبه لي وقت الدراسه كنت باحاول ان انا
وزن ما بينهم لكن بعد التخرج طبعا
فدتني كثير جدا
ودي حاجات برده مشتركه مع الشطرنج
[موسيقى]
هو فعلا في ابحاث اتعملت من الورشه او
بتقال للنسبه
الاصابه بالزهايمر ان هو طبعا شطرنج
تفكيره وكله بيشغل المخ
في اكيد دور كبير فعلا في في الوقايه منها
امراض
بلبس مثلا
[موسيقى]